the other part i want to talk about of
joe biden's uh press conference
yesterday remember joe biden uh
criticized by the right for not doing a
press conference for a while
did one yesterday and took questions for
nearly two hours and some right-wingers
were saying he went on too long the
drudge report had a splash headline
about marathon press conference
he doesn't do one and you criticize him
and then he he answers too many
questions and then you criticize give me
a break guys one person who was
extraordinarily triggered by joe biden's
press conference yesterday and i think
it's both what was in the press
conference and the fact that it's joe
biden doing a press conference rather
than him is donald trump donald trump
putting out a statement yesterday
through his save america
thing
and what he said was how come biden
picks a reporter off a list
in all cases softball questions and then
reads the answer i would never have been
allowed to get away with that nor would
i have to
then donald trump appearing with fox
news host and a radio host i don't
remember if it's westwood 1 or where
mark levin hosts his show
right wing host mark levin and trump is
just completely triggered by the fact
that people paid attention to joe biden
let's take a listen i noticed that i
noticed a lot of things i noticed uh
things that are affecting the american
people directly um he thinks things are
going pretty swimmingly they didn't talk
about crime
they didn't talk about what's going on
in the classrooms they didn't talk about
what's happening at the border
um and he was there for almost two hours
and none of that came up don't you find
that remarkable well crime is so bad
it's so out of control when you look at
these
kids being shoved off subway stations in
new york off platforms right into a
train
now that that's horrible
what on earth does that have to do with
joe biden that it's it's we're talking
about nypd like what they on the one
hand they say
let states and municipalities do what's
right for them
but it's joe biden's fault
that something is happening on the
subways of new york it's tragic but what
does it have to do with joe biden in
full speed and
a young
woman's thrown right into the train
right into the face so as you can hear
by the way this is downer trump right
now very very down low energy the train
killed instantly and
then you look at what happened with the
young lady selling
in a furniture store selling furniture
and somebody walks in and knifes her to
death horrible and
nothing happens to these people nothing
happens and the other question here of
course when we talk about violence in
cities is
they talk about
dangerous democratic democratic run
cities
as many of you know because i've done
this so many times
most cities are done by democrat run by
democrats because more democrats want to
live in cities and republicans tend to
live more rurally so really safe cities
are run by democrats and higher crime
cities are run by democrats because
cities tend to be run by democrats okay
let's continue trump angry with the
reporters during the press conference a
commander-in-chief saying that he
expects russia to invade ukraine
now don't you think vladimir putin heard
that too
well yeah and it was like
the problem is it was like nothing's
going to be done you know another word
yeah i expected now maybe it was a
mistake because it was said in the
middle of another sentence and another
thought
but he said use the words expects that
he's going in
and i thought that was strange
whether you
don't want it to happen or did you know
i just thought it was a very strange
thought to be putting out there that he
what great analysis from trump huh text
him to go in
and nobody seems to pick it up because
the reporters are the most friendly
group of reporters i've ever seen they
don't even ask questions they make
positive statements and then sit down
you know i really didn't see it that way
we i
we have
i i have been endlessly critical of uh
of of the press corps when trump was
president and when biden is president i
think there are often things managed by
the press corps in ways that i think
don't really make sense
uh but that was not what took place
yesterday there were real questions
asked of joe biden biden sometimes
didn't even answer them biden was asked
straight up what happened to canceling
10 grand in student debt he literally
never answered the question he walked
off wasn't wasn't pressed on it so i
have my criticisms of biden of report
but it was not a friendly press
conference in the way trump is
describing here whatsoever
um here's more of uh trump on the press
conference patriots it's a great honor
to have with us this is from the start
of the interview
president donald trump president trump
how are you sir hello mark how are you
i'm doing great president trump
i imagine you saw most of this press
conference and no i did
and joe biden said he's had enormous
progress during his presidency i don't
see it that way do you
well progress in destroying our country
yes i think that's been tremendous uh he
also said something that i assume was a
mistake but
he said he expects putin to go in he
said
uh i expect him to go in
to go into ukraine and i thought that
was a very unusual answer i don't know
if he knew what he was saying because it
was
he said that as part of another question
and he was a little confused because he
tried to correct something yeah that's
part of the biden dementia narrative
which trump continues to push and then
of course at some point it must be
mentioned that joe biden is pushing us
towards communism
uh and that did come up of course as
absurd as it is
you know joe bond says he's not moved to
the left peter ducey said to him why are
you trying to take the country to the
left he says i'm a moderate i'm not a
socialist i'm not bernie sanders
i think his actions defy that don't they
well he says all that he said that
during the debates he said that during
his debates with other democrats and of
course it's true joe biden has not moved
us towards socialism or communism and i
would encourage anybody who believes
that he has to explain exactly which
policies have done so
but it's not true
and you know what he said on energy
you look at what he said on energy look
at what you take a look at religion
what's going on there you nothing what
you know the stance is that these
democrats i mean quite literally nothing
is going on radical left democrats are
taking
uh
no he said all of these things that that
were very moderate and then
he
did things that nobody could believe
bernie sanders cannot believe what's
happening
he said yes bernie is like oh my god joe
you're so far left i can't believe it i
would have never gotten away with any of
this stuff
it's uh it's not it's not really even
believable mark what's happening to me
so trump audibly confused and again look
at biden's actions
tell me which ones are the socialist
communist ones he did covet stimulus but
trump did two of them he rolled out the
vaccine that republicans believe trump
made that's not very far left he passed
a very modest infrastructure bill and he
got out of afghanistan which was trump's
plan
so uh if any time anybody says to you
remember when jesse lee peterson
interviewed me in la
when obama was president
he or no i think no trump was president
but it was about what barack obama did
he said obama was a socialist and i was
like well what did he do and he's like
well he gave some people cell phones
uh that was jessie lee peterson's
explanation so when people say biden is
going socialist communist ask
specifically
which policies are the socialistic
communistic policies i'm curious to see
what people tell you one of our sponsors
is splendid spoon now if you're like me
i love planning my meals out for the
week but sometimes i just run out of
time to plan them for every single day
and splendid spoon makes that whole
process a lot easier they deliver fresh
delicious plant-based meals right to
your door ready to eat no cooking no
cleaning dishes saves you a lot of time
you can choose from over 50 hot and cold
meal options there's smoothies grain and
noodle bowl soups i'm a big soup guy
many of you know that i also really
liked the vegan meatballs with marinara
noodles delicious
both eye and splendid spoon believe
eating more plant-based is a great tool
for feeling good
for helping the environment the list
goes on i'm not vegan you all know that
i think but splendid spoon is really
great to just help me maximize the
proportion of plants in my diet splendid
spoon takes all of the work out of tasty
healthy plant-based meals and you'll
save 35 dollars when you go to
splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below